thunder and lightning suggest something
ominous cliche in this case the movie
itself two and a half minutes of aerial
ice credits oh man they dragged three
actors I really love into this didn't
they
this asshole barely made it over in the
first place now he suddenly can jump
farther even more wait jack had no ice
pick in his hands when he went over the
ledge are we supposed to believe that
after he fell he was able to grab it
from his coat swing it into the ice and
save himself all in one motion when do
you think this could happen professor
when I don't know maybe in a hundred
years maybe in a thousand which
according to the book of scientific
estimations in a roland emmerich film
means ten minutes but what I do know is
that if we do not act soon it is our
children and our grandchildren who will
have to pay the price but you just said
you didn't know when it would happen now
you're certain it's gonna happen within
two generations well the last chunk of
ice that broke off was about the size of
the state of Rhode Island that's the
smallest state in the u.s. that's 1214
measly square miles when it's the size
of Texas get back to me professor I'm
here at the global warming conference in
New Delhi where if you can believe your
eyes it's snowing extremely strange
weather projected to happen a long time
from now just happens to be taking place
during the freakin global warming
conference the names Russ
Terry Rapson professor Robson all good
scientists in movies have heard of every
scientist that ever approaches them has
read their work and remember their
fucking names absolutely we can hail a
cab in India with thousands of people
hailing cabs and making noise in a
blizzard the ability to whistle is not
an asset guy at the important science
research place is sleeping on the job
cliche soccer oh wait we're in Scotland
early so then sin should be football
also Manchester United this guy just
happens to witness the only goal ever
scored in this sport ever
where is 4 3 1 1 ohh the location was on
that very screen when you started
hitting buttons but helpful map the
United States gives the audience a good
idea where it is I guess
to true football fans in front of the TV
and demand players to kick the ball
that's all they can do now so we off
that'll teach you for saying things
excuse me I'm not the one who's away for
months and months at a time
awesome it is job terrible at being a
dad cliche please don't be late I don't
even have to take a taxi again alright
okay I'll be there which inevitably
means no he won't be there because he
sucks why for the love of God would you
aggravate the vice-president cuz my 17
year old kid knows more science than he
does perhaps but your 17 year old kid
does not control our budget neither does
the vice president jack seventeen year
old son probably has as much sway as
that guy does when it comes to the
budgets of government programs what I'm
trying to tell you oh did you forget
something Sam like your son geez
Oh fathers are just terrible aren't they
I got every question right on the file
the only reason why mr. Spengler failed
me was because I didn't write out the
solutions come on four things wrong with
this scenario first like it takes any
time whatsoever to write out your work
on a test even calculus secondly it's
amazing that the teacher didn't give you
a chance to write out your work to prove
that you could do it third it's also
amazing that a straight-a student like
you wouldn't get the benefit of the
doubt
and finally how long have you been
taking this class you don't know the
rules by now oh sure I ask for a second
glass of wine and get the 12-step shame
look but this kid is given 32 packets of
peanuts like it's no big deal
also Emmy Rossum is of an indeterminate
age to be my girlfriend in this scene
how many get 17 but Jake Gyllenhaal is
probably 23 so he can't have her either
chance of a plane going down because of
turbulence is less than what one in a
billion
I can't remember
yeah shut up only black guy I know can I
have my hand back nope just because the
turbulence is over no one on the plane
freaks out about these masks dropping
movie really rips off Armageddon and
thinks we won't notice excuse me sir
we're really late I don't understand the
mentality this is what the traffic looks
like where do you think he can go this
is what you get for stealing scenes from
speed and arguably being the best thing
about showgirls you get the day after
tomorrow birds fly away to signify
danger cliche animals are always the
first to know or think I think it's
because of the consumerism - uma was in
Mexico academic Bowl I'll bet he's
really rich - shut up yeah shut up
only black guy I know one of our Nomad
boys registered a 13 degree drop surface
temperature the other day absolutely
sent you an email despite the fact that
he's an amazing scientist who keeps up
with everything he's somehow missed an
email from another important scientist
and if this happened the other day why
didn't Rapson call him that movie rips
off the wind indicates something ominous
thing from twister should you be
monitoring the weather or something
this is a lay point weather I don't
blame you for trying to ignore
everything to get laid but dude they've
been talking about this hurricane for
days all the way back in the scene when
we found out jack was a bad father yeah
let's just fly a helicopter in the
middle of three tornadoes that's
something I would do if I were getting
that sweet chopper reporter money
dickhead newly-formed la tornado
immediately starts taking out iconic
landmarks ok this footage is coming from
a camera presumably hand held inside a
helicopter that is literally like 50
yards away how is the image this stable
and there are people down there taking
pictures people just worry
yep cellphones are still working fine
during apocalyptic multi tornado storms
from hell we are going live to downtown
Los Angeles right now
Tommy look this motherfucker was
literally just by LAX and not only is
that too far away from downtown LA for
him to be there now
he was also dodging flying cars and
other debris like a soon-to-be dead man
first the weather guy on the street
driving the Porsche then the newscaster
then this guy back at the weather office
who was talking to the Porsche guy on
the phone movie keeps killing everyone
it introduces mr. president Los Angeles
has been devastated by a series of
tornadoes I am somehow the first person
telling you of this news came to
for two planes that were brought down by
severe turbulence so much for one in a
billion yeah shut up only black guy I
know
give me the mainframe let me prove it no
you have 48 hours well Jack did make a
convincing point with that frustrated
face here's where we truly get into
Emmerich Vil there are some major
catastrophes happening we need to care
about all the people like in the world
or else this movie that I paid two
thousand for movie ticket prices to see
terribly wicked mass destruction would
feel a bit hollow also how many other
disaster movies have a main female
character that is a doctor or a nurse at
a hospital
I bet it's easily over 65 percent 16
months I can't be because it's a lot
shorter than you think probably take it
Janet that timescale is it in months
it's in weeks you better be sure about
this Jack my ass is on the line I saw
the model I hope to god it's wrong you
just said that you Opie was right
because your ass is on the line remember
it was found perfectly preserved in the
Siberian tundra stupid kids who bombed
this movie down managed to provide some
over-the-top foreshadow just starting to
fray yep I thought it was about time for
the random people in helicopters get
caught up in a storm and crash cliche
it's my dad's place and he's kind of
never around so so he's just like all
dads that according to this directors
point of view whoops
they're gone oh no the Wolves still
probably only show up again once it's
convenient for the plot in accesible do
we this asshole talks we just go back to
departments yeah what are you King
higher up to the library
boys rich preppy dudes penthouse
apartment not high enough you were all
groaning about taking the stairs so I
can only assume it was pretty high up
right why would a library have more
floors than a rich person's apartment
building anyway I am confused well
luckily I speak French this is basically
Independence Day revisit only the aliens
are now huge tidal waves overly
altruistic girl who heard people in need
of help speaking French in this
commotion and then went back to help is
now going back yet again to fetch a
freaking purse now see this library only
looks to be five or six storeys tall
while all these surrounding buildings
many of which have penthouse apartments
on the top floor are five times as tall
why the did they come here and do
no their projected fine yes our previous
estimates of six to eight weeks weren't
even close and seven to actually strike
that it'll be six to eight minutes wait
six to eight seconds no scratch that
we're fucking dead
I am now communicating to you in the
spirit world
Jack something's happened in New York is
that what the vague bastard on the other
end of the line said are you being a
vague bastard for dramatic purposes oh
sure now all circuits are busy listen
thanks for coming back from me it was
really brave yeah well it's a good thing
you look like I'm you're awesome or
you'd have died also your makeup looks
incredible by the way for someone who
was just out in all that rain for so
damn long Sam just tell her how you feel
suppose that preppy girlfriend stealing
Jurek becomes sudden best buddy
did you reach your little brother yet no
there's still no service damn cell
phones yeah they're so unreliable during
ice ages older payphones draw their
power directly from the telephone line
okay but didn't New York get flooded by
huge tidal waves that likely not power
lines and telephone lines down massive
flooding accounts for something doesn't
it and how is the phone drawing power
from anywhere without shorting out or
giving him a shock and all this water
it's still electricity right movie
spends an awful lot of time trying to
make us think Sam didn't survive this
for you in the library while I'd love to
give the movie points for the clever
library lost-and-found is the source for
dry clothes I can't because no
lost-and-found would have this many
clothes in it besides who takes off
their pants or shirt at the library and
then forgets about it I'm using my body
heat to warm me luckiest hypothermia
ever if we let the blood from their arms
and legs rush back to your heart too
quickly well don't worry about that
because most of the blood is in his
penis right now okay this is where these
fuckers are and I'm calling 100%
bullshit on any boat let alone a boat
this big managing make its way here
through the water streets went on
smashing into a building and getting
stuck how did I even get through the
obviously narrower street it appears to
just come through evacuate everyone
south of that line even if that's the
most scientific answer that's fucking
ludicrous and impossible and I'm not
sure how this smart professor thinks
this would be remotely possible their
best chance is to stay inside try to
ride it out pray but after the storm
didn't you say it was gonna be an ice
age will be staying inside and praying
still help then give the order for the
National Guard to evacuate this stage
the are we gonna tell him to go Mexico
should we tell Mexico to expect 150
million people in the next 12 hours and
won't that create a bottleneck at the
border gentlemen to England yep too bad
you weren't American scientists you
could have survived this you'll kill an
Indian guy much the same way in 2012 you
know we already did 2012 but it's
amazing how
ever copied himself no fur note with
that movie he hasn't been able to reach
Peters parents
oh no not Peter that kid was more
important than everyone else at this
hospital if you were going to get into a
truck anyway what was all that bullshit
or about you walking the whole distance
you can't make it to New York Jack I've
walked that far before in the snow just
half an hour ago Mexican officials
closed the border in the line of so many
US refugees who are fleeing south
tyranny and now dramatic reversal of
illegal immigration oh my god he did not
just say that about also once the
president gave the go-ahead for the
southern states to evacuate why didn't
he speak with a Mexican president to
make sure it was okay you can't hope to
displace millions of people and expect
them all to go what were the choices
taxes parts of Florida that aren't
flooded Mexico I mean you need Mexico in
this scenario you can't find Boggs dean
koontz l ron Hubbard Dan Brown Sidney
Sheldon those kind of books are pretty
much expendable and hey I don't hate
Stephen King but you could throw a fire
starter in there just for the irony not
gonna last very long on M&Ms and potato
chips what about the garbage cans it's
only something to eat in the garbage
uh-huh he's homeless this is only
possible because the president was able
to negotiate a deal to forgive all Latin
American dead Mexico offered a deal with
the United States forgave all Latin
American debt you realize that Latin
America encompasses way more than Mexico
right
how does Mexico speak for every
latin-american country this raises way
more questions than it answers
was there only one patient in the entire
hospital whose family couldn't get there
to pick him up and she's the only nurse
doctor whatever staying behind in the
entire Hospital a Gutenberg Bible I was
in the rare books room I think God's
gonna save you can this dialog have gone
to the main actors in the movie or even
better not written at all and how do you
know looks can be good for something
other than burning oh you you make it
sound like everyone in this room was
part of Fahrenheit 451 s book burning
gang as if it wasn't done for survival
but because it was a pleasure to burn
septicemia
she could go into septic shock I've seen
that before that can get bad thanks
doctor homeless guy she needs a massive
dose of penicillin or a broad-spectrum
antibiotic immediately or what she turns
into a zombie and one of you will have
to figure out who kills her because she
won't be Laura anymore you got me door
to a frozen a ship in the middle of an
historic new Ice Age opens like it's
nothing
we had a piddling ice storm a couple
weeks ago and I couldn't even get my car
door open
oh no the wolves they only came at the
most convenient moment for the plot also
movie expects me to remember something
that happened 45 minutes ago and movie
time if it weren't for the fact that I'm
a smartass it took note of the wolves I
would have completely forgotten and been
like what whoa hey I'm kidding me movie
somehow simultaneously rips off under
siege and inspires the gray all in one
fell swoop hey guys I found it
how do you know yeah shut the fuck up
only but oh you found it good job we
should find some food while we're here
but we don't have time I don't one of
you go deliver the penicillin and the
other to get food it's not like you need
each other to walk to the library and
you don't know about the Wolves yet this
won't broke off from the pack somehow
didn't attract any of the other wolves
during this commotion and now the heroes
are safe goddammit it should be over New
York by now satellite readings are
showing a temperature drop of 10 degrees
per second I know they mean the eye of
the storm but ten degrees per second
doesn't that mean that it's getting cold
and it extremely rapid rate even if
you're not in the eye at that rate
anywhere near the eye the temperature
should be dropping as a speed that would
kill anyone who even looked outside
including our heroes in the shit okay
get back right now it's 10 below no 20 I
mean damn it's 30 below it's 40 below
let's run already all right I beat the
holes it's only negative 1,200 degrees
and now he's frozen oh my god I just
realized this movie is tolerable if you
view it as a prequel to Snow piercer can
I interest you in a frosty Jack is a
dick to his unconscious fellow
scientists movie is literally trying to
create tension through a race against
coal because cold is notorious for being
unable to penetrate doors also look
there in a room with Windows are you
telling me that the insane cold can't
make it through glass that stuff should
be breaking right now does the cold only
follow the paths laid out by the library
Staten Island what do you thinks gonna
happen to us what do you mean I mean us
civilization of course you did it was so
clear by how you freeze the question how
are you alive right now sure you're in a
tent but don't you need massive amounts
of fire and heat for seven to ten days
like the movie said earlier how are you
not cliche sickles at this point I mean
if the movie even tried to explain how
the freezing temperatures and death
conditions worked even once I might not
have so many questions here at the end
mankind survived the last ice age we're
certainly capable surviving this one all
depends on whether or not we're able to
learn from our mistakes after what you
just said it sounds like ice ages
happened with or without our mistakes
Jackie no Sam they're pretty slim I know
because he's inside a stone building
with a fire and we've got this thin tent
and a light affirmative point you're
looking at Fink Italy that is a hundred
percent Europe you space dicks it's
finally clearing earth is listening to
the humans collective consciousness to
stop depending on fossil fuels it took
mercy on us
we're over Europe right now exactly then
why did you answer affirmative about
North America what will really blow your
mind is that that's the ship from 2012
in 2004 it's a total mind of derivative
nests of course they're all asleep there
has to be some suspense I guess for the
dad then his son might be dead despite
the raging fire in the background also
why didn't Jack yell when he got in here
like Oh son are you awake
and if you think schools are closed
today you've got another thing coming
because this is some pussy honest no yes
my father
cheese / Lou consuming our planet's
natural resources without consequence
we were wrong movie that has spent two
hours scolding you for global warming
wraps up with one final scolding about
global warming also why is the president
giving this address on the Weather
Channel again all the weather that
happened but not one single person in
the US would watch a presidential
address on the Weather Channel only a
few hours ago I received word that a
small group of people survived in New
York City sorry mom
it was Donald Trump in the cast of The
Apprentice and Derek Jeter so worst case
scenario this unlikely couple got
married shortly after this helicopter
ride they divorced five hours later
Laura wait how did these assholes
survive did they all have fireplaces in
these buildings I don't see any jimmies
on the rooftops I bet their stories were
better than this one to this unlikely
couple got married
jack is smiling because one day Sam will
have kids with Laura and he too will be
a horrible dad yes in the air so Claire
the three mega storms must have wiped
out all the human produced evil on the
planet IC wiener
I'm sorry I jumped to conclusions
it was a jump to conclusions
Matt you see it would be this Matt admit
one thing can't beat the view so what do
you like about being up here looky here
Buddha these people and their cars and
their exhaust everybody got agents I'm
afraid that my conditioners left me cold
to your pleas of mercy seem looks just
like a hurricane
and then one day he was shooting at
something moving up through the ground
come above them okay so do you need such
a miracle guns lots of I feel happy I
feel happy then let me ask you something
if she chooses me would you try to kill
me that's an intriguing idea but no I
couldn't hurt it like that so you just
turn her into a blood sucking demon like
you I don't want that